- On this episode we
find out how competitive
Kyle really is.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is the Ask Gary
Vee show, episode 288.
And I have a tremendous guest,
a name that even people that aren't fans
of NASCAR I think will know,
just because I think the general awareness
of Kyle overall in culture is quite high
and so I'm excited to have him here,
get a sense a little
bit of his origin story.
I like the comic books in my life,
so kind of comic book episode one
is always kind of
interesting, the first copies,
the origin stories, those
things get me excited.
We'll go into that.
We'll go a little bit
into the current state
of NASCAR from his perspective
and the drivers and the influencer world
and the social media stuff.
And then we will take your calls,
so if you are on Facebook right now
please start putting in your phone numbers
Andy is here, he will select them,
give us a sense of the
kind of question you want
or where you're from.
Feel free to ask Kyle or I
a question of any interest
even if it's not thematically
to what we are talking about
right now, but now we get
to introduce the guest.
Kyle, thank you first of all,
so much.
- Absolutely.
- For being on man.
- Yes sir.
- Good to meet you.
- So,
why don't you tell the Vayner nation
there's a lot of people
on here who know you
a lot who don't, a little
bit about yourself.
- Absolutely, well I'm
the driver number 18
M and M's Toyota Camry
and the NASCAR Monster Energy Cup Series.
Race every Sunday pretty much,
we don't have a whole lot of off weekends,
we run 38 times out of the year.
Now leading the point
standings, currently.
And have been for I dunno last few weeks.
We've been pretty successful, we just won
last weekend actually
in the Poconos.
- Congratulations.
- And that was pretty cool.
- I've gone to the Poconos,
twice, actually.
My father-in-law was the
marketing lead for Gillette.
And when they did the youngguns thing.
- I was a part of the youngguns.
- We actually shook hands
before, believe it or not.
You were a young, I'm
gonna give you the year.
I guess that's 2004, 5,
maybe that range, so.
- I was a younggun, I was a
later, I was a later younggun,
so I wasn't 'till 2009.
- Actually I think that might
still fall into the time,
actually right, we got, so nonetheless,
so I've been to the Poconos,
which is very kind of it's
got a really nice niche to it.
Compared to other tracks.
- It does.
- From what I understand.
- It's got its own understanding,
it's kind of more of
like the Churchill Downs,
like old school, like horse
track racing type thing.
And it's kind of where
they've kind of kept it.
- Have you had huge success there?
- Last two years I won
a race there last year,
I won a race there this year.
- And then were your
first two wins up there?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Gary] So now you're feelin' it?
- I think I'm feelin' it.
- Hat trick next year maybe.
- That's right.
- Awesome, cool.
- It's been a while
gettin' to that point.
- So number 18.
Currently leading the standings,
how do you like, you know
I'm not a deep knowledgeable
NASCAR fan, but I'll put it on at times.
I like to know everything
that's goin' on in life
and I know there was a big scoring change
in the last couple years.
How do you personally just as a human,
forget about even your
official answer to that
probably has to support the sport,
like just as a guy.
Do you like the new?
- Why you lookin' at the
NASCAR guy?
- I'm just looking at them because
just trying to figure out their reaction
to me saying this is off the record,
super on the record.
How do you like it?
Did you like the scoring style before,
do you like this one better?
- So, I like this one better.
- [Gary] Because?
- So years ago, NASCAR history.
- Yeah, educate, educate Seth.
- From '60s, '70s, '80s,
90s, all the way to 2004, it was all about
whoever accumulated the most points
throughout the entire
season was your champion.
- More like the English
premiere league of football
in Europe or there was no playoffs.
- Right, correct,
there were no playoffs.
- So things,
when somebody really broke
out in a big time year
the last two or three four races.
- Were done.
- [Gary] Were done.
- Yeah, the champion
would be crowned two races
before the end of the year.
- Who's the earliest ever, do you know?
- I would say.
- Anybody in this room
have a good sense, like, did Gordan win
with five races to go, does anybody?
Richard Petty win with seven to go,
like does anybody have the record?
- I would guarantee you those exist, yes.
I don't know for sure.
'98, yeah.
- How many races left?
- He won 13 races in 1998
and then he probably won the championship
at least or secured it
with like four races to go.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
Yeah, and the way the tour goes
are the same places in order,
did those last four
tracks always get hosed?
Or last two tracks tend to
have the ability to get hosed?
Or they might've thought
also on the flip side
have the biggest race of the year,
if the way the season played out?
- Exactly, so.
- Understood.
- It's kinda changed.
So the schedule always opens with Daytona
in the beginning of the year
and it always ends with
Homestead, in the end of the year,
right now, currently.
But anywhere in between those points
the races have changed
through the course of me being
in the sport now for the
last 14 years and driving.
- [Gary] I see, I see.
- So the points used to be all the way
throughout the year, right?
Then they started doing points where
you'd have these playoff
points where they would reset
10 guys, 10 guys would make the playoffs
and those guys would start back at zero
and the last 10 races
were really what mattered
for those guys.
- I see.
- And they would race for
championship in those 10.
Well, if you had one or
two bad races in those 10
you pretty much almost
eliminated yourself.
- And did teammates, 'cause
I know you guys are in teams,
did teammates, it must've
gotten very strategic
in those last 10.
Where other teammates were doing things
to other racers?
- Sometimes to get eligible
for the championship.
- What about in the championship?
- I never saw those moments really, but.
- But in those last 10
races everyone's racing?
- Everyone is still racing.
- But if I was your teammate,
even if like, as just a human
if I was really your
teammate and you're lead dog
and you're going for it
and I know Dale Junior's kind of in it
with you kinda sorta.
- You're gonna run him harder, right?
- I mean I don't want to
get politically incorrect
but I would surely like him
to not have a good race.
- So you just run him harder,
I mean I wouldn't say
you're gonna deliberately
crash the guy.
- Right, that's where I was
going.
- But race him harder, right?
- Yes, I would race him harder
and my if I was completely
out of it, which I was,
'cause I'm not one of those 10 guys,
say I was like 13th,
just for my own kind of
competitive nature.
- That's good.
- My sister was born on
the 13th, so I do like 13.
But five's my number, my whole life.
I would definitely do that.
- [Kyle] Yeah, sure.
- That's just a human spirit.
- Some guys probably would.
- Even if coach or owner
or even if you were like,
yo bro, that's not the
fuckin' rules of the sport.
I'd be like cool, I'd be like fuck that,
I'm still gonna do it.
Like you know?
- [Kyle] Yeah, that's it.
- Okay, so that's how it was.
Now?
- Now it is kind of a
mix of those together.
So now you have the whole
regular season we can build up
what's called bonus points.
Playoff points.
And so the more success you have,
you win a race, you
get five playoff points
towards your post-season points.
So when you start the post-season
you've got these points
built up of how your success was.
- But it's still 10 with 10 to go?
- It's still 10 races with 10 to go.
- But when we go to that first 10th,
or that 10th race to go,
you might have 29 points or.
- So right now I have 35
and there's gonna be guys
that are in the playoffs that have zero.
- Zero?
- Right, so I already have 35 point jump.
- That's good, I like that.
- Right?
- So I like that, that's a nice solid mix.
- So what they do then is
you're still accumulating
those bonus points, through the final 10,
so you can keep adding to that total.
The guys that are down there
at zero could get five,
could get 10, whatever, they
could get on a hot streak
and get closer.
And there's a reset every three.
- Okay, you guys had to throw this
I was cruising.
- [Kyle] You were good, right?
- I'm so good, Kyle, I was like this makes
so much fuckin' sense,
I'm like good job NASCAR.
Here comes this horseshit of this.
What is this?
- It's a reset every three.
- A reset every three.
But three.
- Races.
- But three is not, why
don't you make the final
it doesn't even work.
- So what you do.
- Because there's 10 races.
- So you have 16 guys in, right?
- Yes.
- Are there eliminations?
Okay, I can't remember if
there's eliminations, so.
You're not on a mic I got it.
- You're on the mic go ahead.
- I got it.
- Go 'head.
Go 'head, Kyle.
- It goes from 16 guys
for the first three races
and then we're gonna eliminate four.
- Oh, my god, okay.
- Right, then you go the next three races.
- Oh that's kinda cool.
- And you eliminate another four.
And then you go the next three races
you eliminate another four.
- So there's a final four.
- There's a final four, with one race.
- With one race, right 9, oh right, yeah.
And maybe a chance or maybe
somebody's locked it up
based on these bonus points
and things of that nature
or if you crash out in that race
somebody can, so that
final race gets really hot.
- Yes the final race is
all about the four guys
that made it to the final race
that are gonna race for championship.
- But they have accumulated
points, could you like?
- The last race is all zero.
It's whoever beats who.
- Fuck you.
- Points matter, points don't matter.
- So wait a minute, you guys have gone
completely to a American sport, last.
- NFL, Super Bowl.
- All of 'em.
- Last game matters.
- Really NFL.
- Yeah.
- Right because even the
NBA, baseball, hockey,
the other major sports.
- They all have game sevens.
- You're in the NFL business now.
- One and done.
- So wait, so what I'm
hearing which sounds right
which sounds which I
honestly I'll be very honest
as a casual, as a hardcore
sports fan of football
and basketball, big boxing,
other things this and that
all of a sudden, I think
this is a good idea.
I actually now because
of the education of this,
have a far more likelihood
of watching that last race.
Because it's a one,
it's like the reason you
don't get into sitcoms
it's why binge watching
is working with Netflix.
Back in the day when
they didn't have that,
if you missed the first eight
episodes of Wonder Years
you're like, eh, do I
really want to get into it?
Maybe I'll catch re-runs
in the summer, right, now.
- Now you can be behind the
eight ball for the entire season
and then go to the last race and go, okay,
these four guys, got it,
whoever's gonna beat whoever
got it, okay, done.
- But Kyle, one more time,
this is where this one thing
freaks me out though.
Which I think is fascinating actually.
That final race isn't just
the four of you racing
against each other.
- Correct.
- That's some fuckin' crazy shit.
- Okay.
- I'll say it again.
Forget about even teams.
You and I grew up in the same town.
Go Karts and all that
shit that you guys do
on the way up.
You're just my homie.
- We can be homies or we
can be haters, I mean.
- No fair enough,
but let's just say let's
for this story that
I'm about to paint.
We are real friends, like our
wives are fuckin best friends
our first borns have
each other's first name
as the middle name, we are homies.
I'm in this race, I'm out of it this year,
I clearly know which three
guys you're racing against.
It's inconceivable to me
that I'm not in that race
thinking about what nuances
without crashing obviously
but what other thing could I do to impact
you winning this championship?
And I'm not saying this is, by the way,
for everybody listening,
this is not a bad thing
I love things that are complex.
That is really complex.
- That is very complex, yeah.
So last year I got into a little mix up
with the guy in Las Vegas,
the third race of the year.
And it comes all the
way down to Homestead,
I'm in the final four
where I have a chance
for the championship.
There's the guy leading the race,
there's this guy that
I had an argument with,
and then I'm running third.
It took me 12 laps to pass the
guy to get into second place
to go run the guy down
that was leading the race
that was leading the championship
that I'm racing for the championship.
You must win this race
to win the championship.
- [Gary] And?
- And I couldn't get there in time,
because I wasted so much time
passing the other numbskull.
- I love it.
No, listen, I'll tell you why I love it.
I love it because I'm
thinking if I grew up
in a different family, in
different circumstance,
and grew up with this
sport the way I did with
different sport, or to be very frank,
I think listen this is my
whole thesis on NASCAR,
baseball, and everything else.
And how old are you?
- 33.
- Great so you grew up as a child
in a golden era of NASCAR.
- Absolutely.
- On the.
I was such a hardcore, I'm 42.
I was such an early user of ESPN,
I'm talkin' like 1984.
When it was like.
Bull riding and not what the
ESPN that we grew up with.
I by accident consumed a lot of NASCAR
'cause they did a lot of NASCAR, right?
Which was the reason it grew, right?
Like I knew who Bill Elliot was.
- Well he's the sports
most popular driver,
so you should, 16 years in a row.
- Yeah so like, but you have to understand
I grew up in Jersey, where NASCAR,
listen in the '80s and
'90s, when you said NASCAR
people be like, what?
So like, nonetheless, I
think that what I just heard
is exciting because clearly
you articulated it super well
and I think that storytelling,
the reason people watch
the WWE is the stories.
- [Kyle] They wanna know
what happens next, right?
- Of course.
It's a male soap opera.
The reason sports is so amazing.
- [Kyle] It's the divas too.
- Fair.
The reason sports are so
amazing is it's real life drama.
- Yes.
In the moment, live,
it's live action, right?
- You being such a great all time driver
you fall into the class for sure
that people either really love you,
or they hate you.
Because they love somebody else that you
challenge you as a top five racer,
so for me,
I'm just sitting now
thinking if I hate you,
and don't, and or, I want
one of the other three guys
to win that race,
I'm enjoying the living
shit out of those 12 laps
watching that drama 'cause that's real.
And because I'm a hardcore fan,
I know exactly why it's happening.
Me Johnnie Come Lately who's
gonna watch now this year
clearly, I'm not gonna enjoy it as much
'cause I don't know the drama.
Now the announcers may do a
good job and fill me back in
and the beauty of 2018,
I may go to google,
YouTube and try to see
the clip real quick.
And be like, oh shit, they
really hate each other,
this is awesome.
So that's cool, I like that.
- There you have it.
- So it happened?
- It's all the time, man.
- Get out of here with
the commercial stuff.
- You gotta tune in every single week.
- No I, listen, I'm too busy,
well actually you know what,
the Sunday thing works.
- I'm not talkin' to you.
- Well I know, you're
talkin' to the masses.
You've been winning me over
and if you win me over
I think I can bring more
than one person, Andy, you
wanna get really into NASCAR
with me?
- Let's go.
- See?
- He's like just lookin' at him,
like he's totally NASCAR.
- What he's a white dude?
- Exactly.
Yes.
- You grew up in Virginia, right?
- He's like the whitest
white guy in the room almost.
- You grew up in Virginia, which.
- Exactly my point!
- Just a hair too north, right?
- [Andy] Just a hair too north.
- Where's the Mason Dixon line?
- [Andy] Just north of Virginia.
- Is it North Carolina, Virginia line?
Is that the line?
Where's Mason Dixon?
- [Andy] Yeah it's North
Carolina, Virginia.
- All right, well you're right.
- [Andy] I personally take
the start of the north
at (mumbles).
- Understood.
- It's just so different.
- Who'd you love growing up?
- Jeff Gordan was my guy.
- Period.
- Well I liked the sport as a whole.
I liked all the drivers.
- Why?
Your parents were into it?
- My dad was into it.
- Hardcore?
- He was a big, he was a really,
really good race car driver
in Las Vegas, where I grew up,
that's where I was born and raised.
- I knew that, right.
- He won races, he won championships,
he was a really, really good
amateur race car driver.
He never made it professionally,
he never got a break, never got found,
there wasn't this whole
social media presence, right?
So, I always just kind of followed in,
my brother followed in his footsteps first
and then I kinda followed
in after that as well.
And the whole family's been into racing.
So when we were always
watching races on Sunday,
sittin' down, whatever,
I was a fan of the sport.
I just enjoyed it.
But when I.
- Were you a fan of
any other sport?
- Yeah, yeah.
I'm a fan of all sports.
- But what's your second favorite sport?
- Football.
- And who do you?
- And then baseball.
- And who do you like?
- The Denver Broncos.
- And that's, are you gonna do any,
so you're in a real interesting pickle.
If you're a Las Vegas
born, Denver Broncos fan,
and the Raiders are moving to Vegas,
you've got a weird fuckin' situation.
- You're not the first
guy to tell me this.
- And so what's going through your mind?
- I'm a Broncos guy.
- Respect.
- I'm goin' to the home town
to see some Broncos games.
- I really loved you up until this point,
you're a really nice guy.
I've got a little bit mad now,
but I'm hoping you're a hair young
but I don't think you are.
You easily remember the
'98 AFC championship game
against the Jets when you
were losing 10 nothing?
'Cause you were like what, that was '98.
What are we in now?
You were 13.
Do you remember that game?
I can see you don't fully remember it.
- I don't remember that game, no.
- Good, all right, let's move on.
- Okay.
- So you grew up, you were into it.
And do you feel because your dad was a
really, really good
driver and your brother
was really in the sport as well,
was he solidly good, too?
- He's, yeah he races
on the cup tour with me.
- Well fuck, so he's very good.
Like, I always am
fascinated by the youngest
of that lineage.
I always, I think
there's a high percentage
of people at the professional sports level
that have had the luxury
of dad, older brother,
just 'cause of the DNA, the evolution,
and just the competitive nature of
when you're lucky enough
and this obviously with
racing you're gonna understand
it better than I do,
the one on one nature,
but it's fascinating when
you have an older brother
or sister for that matter, in all sports,
actually sister, brother,
sometimes Reggie Miller
had the luxury of his
sister being the greatest
female basketball player.
You just get better.
You just get better,
'cause you're advanced.
Do you feel like you
were effected by that?
- I do because well,
so my dad raced, my brother
raced, they race together.
So then I was always kinda
the one in the grandstands
not old enough to be in the pit,
so I'm video recording the whole race
and going over and filming it.
So then we'd take it home and we watch it
and we dissect it, we go through it,
so I'm listening and learning and watching
and taking all of that
in at a younger age.
And then when it's my turn to do it,
I've already got that
knowledge ahead of time.
I'm ahead of the game.
- Hundred percent!
- So, people would argue, say
that I'm better (mumbles) so.
- How is, how much is the physical,
it's so clearly a big time mental sport.
How much is physical?
I don't know, I'm actually just genuinely,
that's an open-ended.
- It's so physical for sure.
I mean like.
- How so?
- Because unless you're under a caution,
but like the whole time
you're driving you're tense.
- [Gary] As fuck, right?
- Like you're like
holding on to the wheel,
you're like making small movements
sometimes quick movements, you're kind of.
- [Gary] Is it hot as shit in there?
- It's absolutely hot, yeah,
it's gettin' hotter too.
- Like how much do you,
how much weight do you lose
after a race?
- I've seen guys from seven to 11 pounds.
Lose weight.
- That's awesome.
- [Kyle] Water weight during the race.
- Next time I don't eat as
well as I like for a month
I might just go hit the course.
- Go for a run and don't
stop until you lose seven.
- [Man] Race earlier this
season 160 degrees in the car.
- He says 160, because a
thermometer shut off at 159.9.
- That's nuts, man.
- [Kyle] Yeah, it was hot, it was hot.
- Like do people get,
is there a worry about
it getting too hot and
people fainting and shit?
- It happens.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Guy's gotta get out.
Nobody got out in that race, but yeah.
Lower divisions, I think
we're all accustomed to it
we've all been around it long enough.
- Look at the pit, those
dudes are fuckin' amazing.
- The pit crew guys have
certainly come a long ways.
- [Gary] Right?
- It used to be just guys
that worked on your car
now they don't even work on the car,
they are strictly athletes,
they are only solely there
for pitting the car.
- And a specific thing?
- [Kyle] Yeah.
- Right?
Tire changes.
- Are people like I'm the
left tire mother fucker?
Or it is all four tires?
- It's front versus rear.
- But I'm a rear tire dude.
I may be at an airport stuck and delayed,
see some dude and be
like hey what do you do?
He's like, I'm a rear tire
changer for this car number 18.
- [Kyle] Exactly.
That's right.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- Yeah.
We fly private, but yeah.
- Respect.
'Cause you guys are a big team.
Not everybody in the league flies private.
That's what happens when you win.
So, how and actually you
want to get into a question?
This is so fun, though, hold on before,
because actually I need to
do more of these kind of
interviews where I'm like,
dangerously knowledgeable
but not really.
It's kinda like more fun for me.
- Did you google me or did
you just go to nascar.com?
- I flat, I didn't do anything,
I flat out know who you are
but you're right, as soon as
you said your brother's name
like right I've heard, that clicked.
But like I what was
super interesting for me
is my whole life I've wanted
to buy the New York Jets.
And deep down.
- How close are you?
- It's interesting.
I'm not that close,
but I'm doing things
that make me feel close,
so this whole company is being built
to buy like Sprite and then flip it.
Or Puma, so I feel like
I'm pouring all my money
back into this machine.
So it doesn't look in my bank account
like I'm that close.
But I'm.
- Equity.
- But I've got the equity
that can convert very quickly
in a 20 year window.
- Sure.
That's good.
- I always thought that
one of the weird ways
I was gonna buy the Jets
was to do something in an emerging sport.
Ride the wave of the
equity growth and flip it.
So like, the inside joke of my family
that a lot of them know
was I always joked that I would buy
the Milwaukee Bucks.
And I was super right.
Like NBA teams have exploded in value
in the last decade and that
would've been the right bet.
Soccer, MLS, when Steve
Ross, who owns the Dolphins
bought a piece of Vayner media,
and he owns this whole 20
billion dollar Hudson Yards thing
in the negotiation I negotiated with him
with the rights to be
his partner to own the
Miami MLS team, it was
done, it was awesome.
And then Beckham retired and in his clause
when he came from Europe was he could get
a team given to him in any market
and he picked Miami.
So that fucked me up.
And then.
- Do you hate him for that?
- An enormous amount actually.
- Okay, yeah, I would too probably.
- And then finally, I
always thought about NASCAR
and what was interesting
to me was the way.
- You wanna buy a team?
I got one.
- Your team is probably super expensive.
- My truck series team, you can buy that.
- Oh, your truck series
team, I know you're trying to
I understand that, that's different.
What I'm interested in
with NASCAR actually is
I always felt that
marketing was my arbitrage
and I thought I could buy a junior team
or start one and
disproportionately bring in revenue
from brands, worth get a lot more money in
than I deserved based on
the drivers I had at first.
So I've always had, I also
when the dollar stores
first came to America.
This was in the early '90s.
They actually had real
stuff, not the stuff they now
make for the dollar store.
And one of the best flips I ever had
was I bought a ton of NASCAR figures,
the reason I really know
Bill Elliot, like really,
is 'cause I would buy Bill Elliot figures
at the dollar store.
- Well those were probably
the easiest ones to get
'cause they were what all over him?
- White?
- Yeah.
- Huh?
- That's how I remember
it, but I could be wrong.
I thought he was white and blue.
- [Kyle] Mcdonalds?
- Is it possible that he was
not sponsored by Mcdonalds
his whole career?
- Like before, yeah, but,
I don't know that they have
figurines.
- 1989?
- That would've been Coors.
- Yeah, pull up Bill
Elliot, action figure.
Watch this, this is gonna be fuckin' fun.
This is getting like, I
got quiet 'cause I'm like,
now like focused.
See if I can find it.
Anyway, I'll tell the story.
During those action figure days,
yeah these are all the
new ones, red, right,
not this shit.
I'm goin' yeah this is all new shit.
This is like, lemme go 19.
- Look up retro.
- Yeah I'm gonna go 1989, 1988.
- They didn't have those back then.
- Brother I'm telling you right now.
They look like Busch
League starting line ups.
You're gonna shit when I
show you, when I find one.
NASCAR figures, '80s instead.
NASCAR figures, 1986.
- We're stalling.
- We're, I don't care.
Because it's super worth it.
While I'm stalling
I'm so fuckin' obsessed
now to find this shit.
- That one?
- Nope, that's a bobble head, bro.
That's not an action figure.
- It's not a bobble head.
They didn't have bobble
heads back then either.
- Yes, dude, bobble
heads are from the '60s.
They re-fuckin juvinated.
- Not NASCAR ones!
- You Millennials.
All right, so.
- I am not a Millennial.
- Dude, you are, you're square.
- I am not a, no.
- You're an older Millennial.
- I'm not lazy and don't work.
- Don't brand them that way.
I'm a big fan of Millennials,
I think people shit on them
but a lot of them work.
- I just did I guess.
- I know, you did.
Okay, lemme see.
No, dude.
I'll find 'em.
We'll edit it in to here when we find,
I don't want to stall back to your point
I appreciate you enjoying speed as well.
What is, talk to me
about how you think about
so you are one of the
dominant racers in the sport,
so you have endorsement deals
and other business
ventures outside the track.
How are you seeing the social media thing?
When I think about you and
I think about A list actors
and other people that are
at the top of their sports
they tend to look down on
social 'cause they're making
bigger economics, making a commercial,
doing appearance fees,
but recognizing that is
potentially your filter,
how do you see it overall,
because I see it as the way
we build up the long tail
of a bunch of the kids that are emerging
that maybe aren't on the biggest teams,
they may be funny or good looking.
Might not be just what
they do on the track.
What is, I know enough about you as well
from an entrepreneurial kind of
you're not a (foreign language),
back to the comment you made
about the Millennials thing,
I have a feeling your post racing career
could be as grand as your racing career.
One of the reasons I was
excited to have you here, so.
I know a little more than I lead on to.
How do you think about
the social media thing?
The digital age, all of this stuff?
While you're answering, I'm gonna.
- You went into such a huge circle
that there are so many different ways
I can answer that.
- I'm fast, too.
I might not be on a track, but.
- So, in the beginning, let's start with.
Yes, I fortunately have made
it in a perfect enough time
that I still have a decent sized contract
where I can make pretty good money.
But, there's still also the PSAs,
and the other things that are on the side
that you still have the social presence.
Everybody is all about social right now.
And they're all talking about how
to continue to not only market ourselves
and how we can add value to our sponsors
but then how our sponsors
will utilize that social
and that social presence,
the amount of followers
and everything, that we have
to continue to elevate their brand
and everything that they've got going on.
- [Gary] So how do you think about that?
- For me it's a great mix.
And with my partners it, I
couldn't think of a better mix
that I could have with Mars,
which is M and Ms, Skittles,
Snickers, and those folks
because we're actually
doing a throwback scheme
for the Darlington race,
which now is all about
obviously throwbacks,
but it depends on the era
in which different drivers choose to do
their throwbacks from
and mine is Skittles.
It's a Skittles race
this year, so we're doing
an Ernie a 1998 throwback scheme.
Well, Skittles did a
whole video presentation,
we filmed it and produced
it at Joe Gibbs Racing.
And helped our sponsor
launch it through that,
through digital presence.
No commercial, no going to ESPN,
no here where, wherever.
- Sorry to cut you off, racing champions.
- Well that's Richard Petty.
- I know that, I have to
find the Bill Elliot one,
but that's what they looked like.
- I follow now, yeah.
- Got it?
- Okay, I'm with you.
- So anyway.
- They did exist.
They were small.
- You know what's amazing?
This is even better for
me that I found this one.
'Cause it has, the one
I found on the internet,
has the K Mart sticker on it, 4.48.
I used to go to the dollar
store at the Philipsburg Mall
buy them for a dollar,
then walk across the mall
and return them to K Mart for 4.48,
without a receipt, no receipt,
and they gave me cash.
I did this to the tune of making about
four to $8,000 until finally
like a year and a half
into this racket, they were like, hey,
we now have a new policy,
you need to have a receipt.
Which was devastating.
- You started the whole
receipt game?
- Yeah, I think I did.
And then well at least in
Phillipsburg Mall, K Mart.
And then what I did was
I bought one for 4.48
and kind of manipulated that
receipt to be able to use
it to continue it, so I was
unfazed by the receipt scandal
of 1991.
(laughing)
- Is that, never mind.
- So it's probably illegal,
but when you're 14, you don't know.
- It's not illegal when you're 14.
- In the statutory, I'm good now, right?
Like I should be okay, that's
okay that's on the record?
All right, talk to me
about the thing you're most
excited about in sport,
then we're gonna go to
our first question.
- I think what's really,
really cool about today
in our sport is it's
starting to mimic a lot
of what was going on in the '70s,
where you had these really
big powerful three, four,
five guys in the sport that
would win all the races,
but then there was some
more of the other drivers
they're not less drivers,
they're not less.
- The next tier.
- The next tier, right?
And when would they be able to come in
and either a, steal wins
or b, beat these top three,
it's the top three, the big
three right now in our sport,
but when would they be able to beat.
- Big three teams?
Or big three, like racers.
- Drivers.
- Like you, Jimmie?
- So myself, Kevin Harvick,
and Martin Truex Jr.
Have won 16 of the last 21 races.
- Holy fuck, one more time.
- 16 of the last 21 races.
- The other two dudes?
'Cause I would've, you
notice how I said Jimmie
'cause I still thought Jimmie,
'cause I'm not paying as close attention.
You?
- Kevin Harvick.
- Whose a big deal, who I'm aware of.
The third guy I haven't heard of yet.
- Martin Truex Jr.
- Martin what?
- His last name's Truex?
- He's a Jersey guy.
- Yes.
- And he's a Jersey guy?
- He's from Jersey.
- He's my favorite racer.
- I would imagine so, yeah.
I'll introduce you.
- Please, DM me.
- Okay.
- His last name's Truex?
- Yes.
- That's fucking amazing,
like you could do so
much marketing with that.
Okay.
And you hate him right?
- No I don't.
- You like him as a guy but
you wanna bash his fuckin face.
- On the race track?
- Yes.
- Okay, I'll admit that.
- Thank you.
Of course.
- He's actually kinda my teammate, but.
- Oh, that whole weird
dynamic, which I like.
But the other guy's not your teammate?
- No, uh uh.
- Is he black and yellow, the other guy?
- He's, what is he?
- Trying to think about.
- Yeah, he's Busch, Busch beer.
- Got it.
- He's my last name.
White and red.
- White and red, okay.
- Or white and black.
- Got it.
- Jimmie John's white and black.
- What's goin' on with Jimmie?
He just, he had a great career,
is he starting to tail a little bit?
- Jimmie's had a long career.
- [Gary] He's having a bad year.
- Unfortunately the
Hendrick guys have kinda
tailed off a little bit, so.
- [Gary] Is that right?
- Yeah, the Hendrick
group, the whole group,
they haven't won one is 365 days.
- Shit that's.
- [Kyle] That's like the first time ever.
- They're freakin' out over there.
- [Kyle] Oh yeah.
- Are they blaming, who are they blaming?
- They're not blaming anybody.
- They're blaming somebody!
- They're workin' hard, man.
They're trying to turn it around.
- All right, they're blaming themselves,
that's winner talk.
But they're blaming somebody
like the fuckin' car
manufacturer, something.
- [Man] Chris.
- Why are you calling me?
- Chris who?
From California?
- [Chris] Hello this is Chris.
- Chris, you're on with Gary and Kyle.
- [Chris] How are you guys?
Kyle, you are the man.
- Hey whatsup?
Hey thanks, man, 'preciate that.
- What about me, bro?
- No, you're the guru,
well I won't use guru.
But Kyle, I've corrupted my 13 year old
into watching you back in
the monster energy days
and also when you were
running the 54 on the truck.
- Oh there you go, nice.
- Love it.
Love it, real fans.
What's your question, my friend?
- [Chris] I am a very big car enthusiast
I guess we'd call it NASCAR super fan.
But, more importantly,
I am starting a podcast
with Rodney Allen Rippey,
from jack in the box fame.
And he is a huge car fan.
We have gone out and done the
social media test marketing
we'll call it, with the nostalgia
that you're so big in.
And it's gone very, very well.
When it's his base, his name,
anything to do with the
past and the history
we do very well and if
it's a new current face
we put him with, just about anything.
But we got one great
shot of launching this,
we're gonna do it in Sima 2018 this year.
- You're already over,
lemme give you a very good
piece of advice.
Do not put that fake pressure on yourself
that you have one chance
to launch this thing,
it's the biggest mistake that people make
with media properties and businesses.
They think, especially if
you haven't done it before
or it's natural human nature, right?
You wanna come out the gate,
it's probably no different
than starting Daytona off
on the right foot, like
everything, like when I launch.
- You wanna win right away,
you ain't gonna win right away.
- That's right.
- You gotta build in to it.
- I really don't want, here's
why I'm most worried about
it my friend.
I don't want you to do
behaviors that so over value
the short term in something
where you're playing for life.
You're trying to build
something that you hope
pays for your livelihood,
around a passion you have,
I assume, right?
The idea is, you'd love for this to be
whether it's a podcast
or a media property,
this is what you do for
the rest of your life,
making the kind of money that lets you
live the lifestyle you want.
Is that correct?
- [Chris] It's one of a few components.
I am definitely on your
willing to eat shit
as long as it takes mode.
- Good, so then I would
say everything sounds great
don't over worry about the launch.
Because it may be episode 96
that really turns the tide.
Does that make sense?
- [Chris] Okay.
Absolutely.
- And the luxury you have
is that you don't work for
a television network, like
ESPN didn't buy the rights
to you and then the ratings
were bad after three
and they cancel it.
You have full control of
content and distribution,
you don't have to worry about popping
because you're not at the
mercy of Nielson ratings
and advertisers and all the other dynamics
that traditional media had to worry about.
If you had a radio show 20 years ago
around this subject matter,
if your first six weeks didn't go well
you're finished, I mean here in New York,
Mike Francesa was the legendary sports guy
he left, retired, they put in a show,
it lasted like five weeks
and Francesa was back.
'Cause the ratings weren't there.
You don't have that, so don't,
I think before even ask the question
to make the launch pop,
make sure that you realize you
don't need the launch to pop.
It'd be nice for it to be great,
but don't over worry about that.
- [Chris] Perfect, I
really appreciate that.
It's to the point where
I've got some good guests
lined up and things,
and we're goin' out at
a really good time and
it's just a matter of
I didn't want to leave
those four other things
on the table, partly
'cause I didn't know what
these next four things should be.
So, that's helped out very well.
- Good, yeah, let it come to you, I think.
You know Kyle, just for fun here,
just 'cause I love sports and strategy
and the story, I promise you in 19 years
when I run into you on something,
I'm gonna recall this
'cause I don't forget things
that hit me, the fact that
you recorded those races
it was over before it started.
You were so mentally knowledgeable.
- Yeah.
- It's how I think about everything.
That's such a remarkable
advantage that you had.
- I would presume that
that's why I could be as
good as I am today, but I
would say that it's also
due to a lot of hard work
over the course of years.
- No question, no question.
- But there was a basis,
there was a start, so.
- Just knowing how the
chess moves played out
and so, lemme ask you a question.
Based on that and this is gonna
help Chris here a little bit
I'm very curious about how you handle
a bad start to a race.
To me the psychology of
everything is so interesting
I just know for fact without
knowing any of the racers
that there's a certain percentage of guys
who if it doesn't start right,
are just in a bad place.
- I would agree.
Absolutely, I've had those moments.
I would admit that when
something bad starts
and it doesn't quite go right
that it's like, ugh, it's
over before it started
or whatever, you start
cussing on the radio
and throwing everything
all over the place.
- Yelling at somebody on the team, right.
- Right, throwing people under the bus,
whatever it might be but.
Sometimes you can work
your way back out of those.
- What is the greatest
work your way out of race
of your career?
- [Kyle] Oh man.
- Like really go there with me now
'cause I think it's interesting.
Do you remember a race or maybe
like the first 10 laps or fuck I dunno
like all four tires fell off the car?
In the first lap and then you won it.
Like, if you really thought
buying you some time here to think.
Really thought about like, what's the race
that I won in my career on the big stage
that in the series, not earlier than that,
that I did not think I was,
like the one that I most, that I won,
that I most did not
think I was going to win?
- There's plenty of those out there,
I would say that there
was a race at Walkins Glen
years ago, where the first few pace laps,
you're scrubbin' your
tires back and forth,
you're speedin' up slowin' down,
tryin' to warm your brakes up and stuff.
And you feel that the lead
within the frame rails
of the car, in order to
make the car make weight
to go over scales, is loose.
Like nobody put the spacers
in there that hold the lead
tight against the bolts.
So it's sliding forward
when you're on the brakes
and it's going backwards
when you're on the gas.
So it keeps moving and it's a big slam,
like this is 80 pounds sliding
around in the frame rail
of the car.
- I have no idea what he's saying,
but it sounds so fuckin' smart.
Keep going.
- So we had to come down pit road
before the race started
and actually take the frame
the bolt out of the frame
rail put the spacers in there
to space it back where it needed to be,
put the bolt back in,
and I had to start in the
back and I came back through
and I don't recall if I won that one
but I know that.
- What the fuck?
That was the whole point of.
Dude, for a minute.
- I know I finished top five,
but I don't remember if I finished second.
- Tell me the truth when you first started
telling this story, you thought you won,
and as you were telling it,
you're like fuck, wait a minute,
maybe I didn't win.
- No I thought.
- And these internet dudes are like,
and they're like fuck you dude,
you came in 13 seconds off the pace.
- Which one?
Well, yeah.
- Hold on, hold on, what?
He broke his foot and won the race?
- [Man] Both feet.
- And won the race?
- Okay, no, no, no, no, no.
- [Chris] No, it's different than that.
- Yeah.
- Tell me what it was, tell me what it is,
tell me what it is.
Get in here.
Chris, get in here, what was it?
- [Chris] It was Daytona, had a bad crash,
was out a good portion of the season.
- And the first race he came back?
- [Chris] Probably some
of the most determinated
person there is in racing.
Who came back in and pointed
his way into the championship
and won it.
- I also won races by the
way, to get my way back in.
- I get that.
- But yeah.
- [Chris] Yeah.
- So wait, you think Kyle
is really awesome, right?
Does your son like obsess over Kyle?
- [Chris] Yes, more so in trucks and Busch
because they're shorter
races and he doesn't have
the attention span.
- Attention span.
- [Chris] But that's why he started back
when Kyle was still runnin' the 54.
- Yeah, yep, those were the truck days.
- I understand, I understand.
- [Chris] The other thing
is Kyle's got 92 wins
in the secondary series of what
I'll call the Busch series.
- Okay.
- And we went so often
that we watched Kyle win
every weekend when we were there live.
- Let's actually talk about this,
so you're telling me your
son is a front runner?
And jumps on band wagons?
- [Chris] No, he started
in diapers at two years old
watching Kyle.
- I love it.
So that means you made him watch Kyle.
'Cause I don't know any
two year old that's like,
oh there's Kyle I'm gonna be a fan.
- [Chris] He you know he loved Hot Wheels.
And Hot Wheels were live
and they were racers.
- Listen, this is good battle Chris,
I respect where you're comin' from.
Listen, don't.
- M and Ms probably had
something to do with it probably.
- Let me give you a piece of advice,
it sounds like you're
also doing some content
with new faces, when you do that
run Instagram and Facebook
ads to the tune of $100
to $1,000 a piece, around
people that are fans of
those things.
- [Chris] Okay.
- Like for example, I'll
take this Ask Gary Vee show
and we will run this episode
on Facebook and Instagram
against fans of.
- [Man] We're doing it
with the live right now.
- We're doing it with the live right now.
We're running ads against
this live right now
against what?
- [Man] NASCAR.
- So, it's really, what's
amazing about the new world
is Kyle's getting new exposure to my world
and all the entrepreneurs
that're watching.
And honestly I think what's
more interesting to me is
entrepreneurs tend to be very creative
and get caught into storytelling.
I'm just fascinated how
many people are actually
gonna watch or become fans off of this.
That's how it all works.
And vice versa you'll be able to do that
with the people that
you put the new faces on
with him, so make sure
you do that as well, okay?
- [Chris] Absolutely,
yeah and I'll tell ya
I'm not a band wagon guy.
- I know, I know you're not, no.
I was making a joke brother.
- [Chris] My dad was a senior fan,
my mom was a DW fan, so
for the NASCAR people,
they'll know that.
- Yep.
- Nice.
- [Chris] I was an Allen Quickie fan,
unfortunately he passed
away champion in a crash
at Bristol and I followed this guy,
followed Jeff Gordan, so I've
been around there forever.
- I respect that buddy, I'm jokin' around.
- Nice.
- Take care.
- Right on man, thanks.
- Good guy.
Let's get another one like that,
that was probably the best
call you've ever picked.
You've been cold, you're kinda like,
you're like Jimmie on the Hendricks team,
you're cold right now.
And so you need to pick it up.
So wait, this guy's last name was Truex?
- Yeah.
- Yeah I'm very excited about this
and what, do you know what part of Jersey
he's from do you?
'Cause.
- Alpharetta?
- Is that right?
- Mayetta.
Mayetta.
Mayetta, New Jersey.
- I was like Alpharetta.
- Alpharetta, that's Georgia.
- Yeah, Alpharetta, that is it is Georgia.
I was like, why do I know that?
My friend Moose lives
in Alpharetta, Georgia.
By the way, Atlanta traffic sucks shit.
- So does Charlotte, man.
I-77, is terrible.
- You hate it?
- Oh gosh, yeah.
- The Broncos, Raiders thing, Kyle.
I'm tellin' you that's
gonna become a big deal.
- Hey, I dunno, man.
- Do you love Bryce Harper?
'Cause he's from Vegas?
- Yeah, he's from Vegas.
He's cool, yeah.
- You like that?
- Yeah, he's a good dude.
- He's a really good dude.
I'm fascinated by that guy,
I think he is, I think the baseball system
has suppressed how much
of a superstar he is
as a person and I'm fascinated by.
- He's like one of the
only baseball players
that I even know of today.
- Did you catch that whole controversy
where the commissioner
of baseball kinda threw
Mike Trout one of the best,
if not the best player,
kind of under the bus
during the all star weekend
saying it's up to him to
build his personal brand too?
- I missed that.
- It's very interesting
'cause I do think baseball
and NASCAR actually very
ironically are in very similar
spots, in different ways.
Where there's so much gold
and it just needs to be mined
a little different, a
little more contextual,
a little more storytelling,
like to me, you and this
dude who blocked you for 12
fuckin' laps, you guys need
to go into a steel cage
arm wrestling live on Facebook.
- We kinda did.
- In week three.
- You fought?
- Did you throw your helmet in his face?
- I didn't throw no helmet,
I threw something else.
- A punch?
Have you guys, where are you guys now?
- He.
- 'Cause I once punched my brother AJ
on a basketball court and
I've never really said it,
because I don't want to
admit it actually happened
but it actually, you were
there Andy for that one?
- [Andy] I've heard the story.
- You were there for that
one, or I think this was
before when you guys played.
- [Andy] It was the
one where you threw him
against the wall.
I don't know who threw who.
- Here's the bottom line.
I understand the difference
between the heat of the battle
and real life.
Like I'd die for my brother, AJ.
And I've done remarkable things
that I feel very proud of
for my brother.
But I really kind of, weirdly punched him
for a boxing out situation that
I thought was inappropriate.
So, are you cool with this
guy or is it still lingering
and there's a real heated
controversy still brewing?
- He tried to put a kabosh to it,
'cause he didn't really
want any more lingering
after he'd boxed me out
of the championship race.
- Lemme ask you a question.
'Cause I wanna learn,
I wanna learn the sport
through your experiences.
Let's say you guys didn't
have that little beef
in week three.
Would it have been the
unwritten rule for him to let
you have that chance, to try to win it?
If you guys were teammates or?
- So he first and foremost
should go out there
and try to win the race.
If he's gonna go out there
and try to win the race
and he's gonna be catchin'
that guy that's in front of him
more power to him to stay in front of me.
When he's fallin' back
and that guy out front
is getting farther away and I'm up his ass
tryin' to pass him and
he's tail blocking me.
That's like, that's bad.
- And that was that bad.
- Not bad, I mean, he
can do whatever he wants.
But, pisses me off.
- As he should.
I'm tellin' you I really,
this is, this final race thing
let's make it a real Vayner media thing,
let's get really into the
final race of the year.
When is it?
- Homestead, November 18th- ish.
- On a Sunday?
- Oh yeah.
- That's a problem.
- See?
- Well the Jets are playing.
Now, what time?
I don't know if you know this, Kyle.
I don't know if you know this, lemme me,
off you reaction, I just
want you to understand.
I got married in November
and went on my honeymoon
in February, in case the
Jets made the playoffs,
both of my children.
- Why would you ever need to do that?
- Stop it.
Both of my, don't make
me become a fan of number
guy who blocked you for 12 rounds.
I also have two children
born in summer months,
and literally not like by accident,
like my life revolves around the Jets.
- Did you have IVF babies or no?
- No, but we strategized.
- You practiced during that time of year?
- We focused on that time of year,
more than practiced, it
was like, try to achieve
non-baby life during football season,
because I would pick the Jets
over my children's birthday parties.
- Okay.
- That's firm.
So your fuckin' Homestead
is a easy one for me.
Now!
What time is Homestead?
- Probably three o'clock.
- Check November 18th
Jets schedule right now.
Ooh, you know what, is that their bi-week?
I'm going to Homestead.
- Just look up what week it is for sure,
it's around, I dunno if that's the day,
is that the day?
Gimme the Sunday.
- Very important.
The Jets are on bi.
Are the Jets on a bi?
- November 18th, 3 o'clock start.
(clapping)
- The Jets are on a bi.
This is a fuckin' sign.
I'm gonna go crazy at Homestead.
Where is it?
- Exactly.
- No where is it?
- In Miami?
- It is not in Miami.
- It's in Homestead, Florida?
- It's Miami Homestead, Florida, yeah.
It's like an hour from Miami.
- [Hannah] We all went last year, Gary.
You missed out.
- We all went?
What's this we all went?
- They all together didn't
invite you to go to the race.
- [Hannah] It was like eight of us from.
- And this was last year
when you got blocked?
- Yeah.
- When he was getting
blocked, did you understand
what the fuck was goin' on, Hannah?
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- Were you like, this
is super controversial?
- [Kyle] No she didn't.
- I know she didn't.
I know she didn't.
All right, so clearly breaking news
there's a significant chance
I'm gonna be in Homestead
my wife's watching this
right now being like,
this fucking guy.
The only bi week when our family
actually can have a normal
weekend, now he has to
go to fuckin' Homestead?
Anyway, all right let's
give one more question
and this is too fun.
Are you good at social media?
Or do you let a team take care of it?
Like, do you personally go in there,
will you do anything?
- I do a little bit.
- What do you like to do?
Twitter, Instagram?
What do you like to do?
- I don't even know how
to post on Instagram.
- Jesus Christ.
- I have a guy, he's behind you.
- I get it but.
- I go on Twitter.
- You know what that was to me,
that's like me saying to you like,
I don't know how to drive a car, at all.
(laughing)
That was literally what you just said.
Just so you know.
- You live in New York, do
you know how to drive a car?
- Of course I grew up in Jersey,
I really know how to drive a car.
(laughing)
- One that has scratches and dents and?
- Actually you know what?
- [Kyle] What do you drive?
- I drive a Land Rover.
- [Kyle] Okay.
- Not a car that, like
I've never driven like
I'm trying to think if
I've had anything sporty.
I had, you know Lincoln
once made a sports car.
For like four minutes.
It was the craziest thing out of nowhere
from like the big fuckin' huge town car,
in the late '90s which
was fast I loved it,
but yeah I didn't grow up car oriented
or racing, what I'm crazy though about,
the way I drive is
actually completely wild.
Can somebody find Nate or Phil Toronto?
Actually find Nate, or
Phil Toronto right now.
See if Nate or Phil are out there.
This is actually very important.
'Cause I think I'm gonna
impress Kyle right now.
- What if people are not
gonna answer your call
because they don't know
what phone number's calling?
- Then we say fuck you and
they fuckin' missed it.
They're gonna be so, imagine
how pissed they are right now.
- They have their phone they're like ah,
leave a message I don't know who this is.
- Are they comin' through?
I want one of those two, I
really hope they're there
because I think I think that
you're an all time great
racer and I still think
at the end of a Jets game
to get back to my apartment,
I think I can beat you.
Because I am completely
an utterly out of control
in traffic.
- Beat me like after a race?
- No, I mean.
- After a Jets game
beat you back to your
apartment, I got you.
- Correct because it's not racing.
It's understanding traffic
and being willing to break
every law.
- Well yeah you have
every advantage over me.
- Well I'm trying to win
this, they're not here?
- [Man] No.
- Anyway, I like drive on curves,
I'm really into time.
- See TV, I was gonna say
we could make a TV show
about that or a pod, or
not a podcast, but a vlog
about that, but.
- Me versus you.
- That's against the law.
So like, didn't get a ticket.
- So let's just do it
and then be renegades.
What?
- So I did this one thing one time
there was a radio show host
out of Washington, D.C.
And they would bring in
celebrities and stuff
and they would do a beltway race.
- Okay.
- So you start at one point,
you start at the radio station,
you get on the beltway, you go
around the beltway for a lap,
you come back to the radio station, right?
So while the cops are
standing on overpasses
and they're looking
and whatever, whatever,
so they're talking,
like we're live on phone
on the car phone.
- That's amazing.
- Back to the radio station.
- Yeah.
- So they're asking us
okay, well where are you at?
So I'm leading and I'm
a half a mile to almost
three quarters of a mile
ahead of the other one
behind me, right?
'Cause I'm gettin' through
traffic pretty good
and stuff.
So a cop pulls me over.
And puts me on the side of the road.
And I'm yeah what did I do?
You didn't do anything, I'm
just letting the other guy
catch up and I'm like,
this is frickin' rigged.
- Amazing.
- Like, really?
- So then as soon as
the other guy passes me
he lets me go.
- [Gary] And you still won?
- Well, no, so then, the
reason why this all ended is
because we started racing
on the street racing.
Like door to door.
And like getting back
to the radio station.
So he turns into the
radio, traffic's coming
and he turns into the radio station
and I turn in underneath him
and I just door slam him.
Like car to car, just door slam him.
And I beat him back to the door.
- You know I gotta tell you.
- And so they were like
we can't do this anymore
like that's, that's like
too many liabilities
and things like that.
I was like I didn't give a
shit, I'm gonna door the guy.
- I'm very into you.
You're now my favorite racer.
Like I would do that.
That's right.
- Absolutely.
So like you can't do that, though.
- To me, Ivan Drago said it best.
If he dies, he dies.
I mean listen that's just
a way to like live life.
That's just a good way to live life.
Are you getting a call?
- He's trying.
- Right, who's this?
Amy?
All right.
(phone ringing)
- Wonder if I know this Amy.
- Wow, you door slammed,
that's exactly right.
- Do you do that?
Do you door slam guys?
- Listen, when I compete,
I'm literally willing to do anything.
Chemicals change in my body.
- Hi.
- Hi, is this Amy?
- Hi, Amy.
- No, I'm not Amy.
Are you Amy?
- Are you Amy?
Or is your mom Amy?
- [Man] They might be.
- My mom's Amy.
- Can you get her?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
Mom, they want you.
Whoever.
I'm Everett.
- Oh, Everett, you're Everett!
- Everett.
- Hey brother, how are you?
- Hey!
- How old are you?
- I'm seven.
- Amazing, are you watching
the Ask Gary Vee show
with Kyle Busch right now?
- [Everett] No, but I'm
about to go over there.
- Okay, fantastic, do you have a question?
- Yeah.
- What is it?
- How did you get into racing?
- How do you get into racing?
All right, good question,
I mean it's not very simple.
It's not like going and being
in little league baseball
and picking up a bat
and a glove and a ball
and going and playing at
your local field, right?
So, getting into racing
is getting a Go Kart,
like it's expensive, you
have to go out and buy
the things to be able to
go out here and do that.
- [Everett] Yeah.
- Racing at the local
level is where I started.
I started in Go Karts first,
messed around with those for a little bit
and then got into legends
cars are more expense.
Everything that you keep getting into
is more and more expensive,
but the reason why I kept
moving up and getting into
those things was because I kept winning
in what I was racing in.
- I was about to say,
when you start winning
at such a youth level, do
sponsors start coming in
and subsidizing families?
- Not, yes and no.
Not at my level, so when I was.
- [Everett] That's actually
pretty neat that you started
in Go Karts.
- Are you in Go Karts?
- [Everett] Yeah.
- You are?
- [Everett] Well not racing 'em
but I have a Go Kart at home
that I drive.
- All right.
- [Everett] And a four wheeler.
- Well there you go.
Heck yeah.
- Are you gonna be a
NASCAR driver one day?
- [Everett] Yeah.
- I really hope so.
- I'll start buying all
kinds of things.
I just wanna race.
- You just wanna race?
Well that's all I ever
- Yeah.
- Wanted to do.
- [Everett] Doesn't matter who wins,
I just wanna race.
- That's exactly right.
- And why do you wanna race?
- [Everett] I don't
know I just got into it.
And that's how it happens.
- Is it because you like
to win?
- [Everett] Well I watched
the Richard Petty race
and bam, racing started.
- Do you like beating
other people in race,
when you race, do you love
destroying the other kid?
- [Everett] Well, every single time I race
my Go Kart, I beat my dad on,
he raced a four wheeler,
he races a four wheeler
and when he works on body shops
but I'm the racer.
He didn't know what
racing was or anything.
- Everett, do you think
your dad's letting you win
'cause you're such a little kid,
or are you destroying your dad's face?
- [Everett] He's lettin' me win, but,
I don't want that.
- You don't want that,
well you should tell him
to stop that.
- What is your last name Everett?
Because it's very
important, because one day
when you're winning championships,
I'm gonna clip this, air
it, and get millions of
viral views.
- [Everett] My last name is Larson.
- Wilson or Racing?
- [Everett] My last,
our last name is Larson.
- Very good, I didn't catch it.
Everett, listen, thank
you so much for calling.
- That's awesome.
- You're welcome.
- Hey, Everett you go out
there and you kick your
dad's butt and tell him that
you're the best, all right?
- [Everett] Okay.
- Everett, before you go,
tell Kyle to stay in racing
long enough so when you get there,
you destroy his face.
- [Everett] Okay.
- Awesome.
- All right, all right.
I'll give you 10 years, buddy.
- Is that, on that, what do you think?
- What's that?
- Talk to me about one thing
I've been fascinated by
in professional sports is,
when I was growing up it
was unheard of for guys
to play at the highest
level at 37, 39, 41.
Conditioning, look, underlying
performance enhancing drugs
there's a lot of things
that may be contributing
to this evolution of 365 cycles,
guys not just taking, you
guys are on all the time.
But like, drinking beer
during the off season.
How much longer do you think you can race
and do you feel like it
is a young man's sport?
Or, is there a fall
off at a certain point?
- I hope that, oh there you.
- That's him?
- [Man] That's him.
- Nice.
- He's awesome.
- That is perfect.
- He's amazing.
Everett is amazing.
- I hope that I get to
go another 13, 15 years.
I mean I dunno, there was guys.
- Who was the oldest and most competitive?
Richard Petty seemed to be old.
- No, Richard fell off his
last eight years at least,
so Mark Martin.
- Who would you say is the
best oldest?
- Won at 53?
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- That's awesome.
- Rare, yeah.
- He won a Winston, that
was when it was Winston cup?
- No, well he raced in
the sprint cup, yeah.
- Oh right, in the sprint.
- 2011 was his last year?
- So what do you think?
You think you've got
that many years in you?
- I'm thinking, so I'm
33, I'm thinking like,
mid-forties I'm probably about done.
See a lot of those guys,
so they started older.
So they started at 35, 33, 35, so.
- Is that right?
- They started racing.
- Back in the day.
- Cup, yeah.
- Because what?
- Because it just took
them longer to get there.
And because nowadays
everybody gets there sooner,
like kids they start sooner,
18, 20, 22, whatever,
they're starting sooner,
so then the sponsors
can stick with them for longer, right?
- I understand.
- So, back then it wasn't that way.
- I totally understand.
- Where now so I started
my first year in cup
I was 18 years old.
So, if I was 18 when I started,
those guys were 33, they retired at 53.
- Bill Elliot's kids
in the game now, right?
- He is, Chase.
- How's Chase, how's
his career starting off?
- Um, Chase is he's good, he's talented,
he does a really nice job.
He's very polished and talks
well, but he hasn't won yet.
- Right, until you win
you gotta break through.
- He's been close,
actually, his closest he was
I stole the win from him, so.
- You feel good about that?
- I don't feel good about that.
- What are you talking about?
You should feel tremendous about that.
- It was a badass finish.
I mean I must say, there was 40 laps to go
and I was four seconds back.
- Was the old school
establishment that loved his dad
super pissed at you?
- Oh, absolutely.
- Was Twitter like fuckin' Kyle.
- People were blowing
me up, like screw him,
he's an asshole, like he
shoulda let Chase win.
I'm like, shoulda let him.
- Shoulda let Chase win.
- What?
- I'll fuckin' punch
Everett the eight year old
in his face to beat him in
any game we play tomorrow.
There is no should let win.
- Right, exactly, no
more, there's no ribbons.
There's no participation trophies.
- Talk, talk.
- [Man] Signature move after
winning and the crowds booing.
- 'Cause you're like fuck you crowd?
- I do a bow.
- Yeah.
- Like see I'm from Vegas, showman shift,
like every show in Vegas ends with a.
- A bow, yeah, I love that.
- Right, so that was me, yeah.
Oh, that's another one.
So the other one is like, cry baby.
- Now, see if we do this a little longer
I'm actually gonna become a fan.
Are you genuinely so
good outside of everybody
who's a fan of you
basically hates you land?
- Oh, yeah.
- Are we in like John Seena land?
Oh, yeah.
- I love it, dude.
- [Man] Just the cryin' eyes.
- Yeah dude, this is starting to get good.
Problem for me is when I
get into something new,
I have to go with somebody
who's not winning.
'Cause it's too front running
I love that you're a dick.
- Well you've got plenty to choose from.
(laughing)
- So Chase is emerging.
What about that gentleman
that I saw profile
on Sports Center one early morning
'cause of my son now I'm
watching Sports Center again.
The Japanese American dude?
Right?
- Kyle Larson.
- Yeah talk to me about him.
- He's good.
He's won, he's won
before, he's won, he won
so we go to Michigan next week, right?
So that's like his track.
He's won there like three times in a row.
- Really?
- Yeah, I think, I dunno where
he finished in the spring
race there this year, but
he's always fast there.
- So he's having a solid
nice young career so far?
- So this year he hasn't
won a race this year, right?
He hasn't Kyle Larson.
- So he's accelerating.
The way that him and his fans would hope.
- Last year I think he won four races.
Year before that he won two or three.
- I see.
- And this year they're all kinda.
There's a lot of guys on a dry spell,
I mean 16 of 21 races have
been won by the big three.
- That's insane.
- So.
- And how, this big three
feels fairly new though, to me
like are the other two guys,
the other guy I heard of,
the Truex guy I haven't,
but again I'm not.
How long is Truex been good?
- Two years.
- Right so he's fairly
new, that makes sense.
- Yeah, yeah.
What else?
- You hate him, right?
- I don't hate him.
- I saw it in your eye.
I'm so pumped right now, you
wanna fuckin' break his face.
I love it, dude, Kyle,
honestly it makes me love you
so, by the way, bro, I'm serious.
Again, the AJ thing I'm telling you.
Like Andy knows, he knows,
I'm terrible on the court
or like, I'm a bad dude
when it comes to competing
'cause I wanna win so bad.
And that's what you're supposed to do.
- [Kyle] That's what
you're supposed to do.
- What you did to Chase is exactly right.
And by the way, do you know how I think?
I think that probably
helps Chase in the macro
or it doesn't, it exposes Chase.
If he crumbles at a
devastating last second loss,
then he was never meant
to be great anyway.
And if he's meant to be great,
he'll fuckin' go on and fuckin' dominate
and probably reference that race one day.
- [Kyle] Absolutely,
that's the way he should.
- Who crushed your soul as a rookie?
What was the closest win
you had before you had a win
that you got hurt?
Or did you kind of not have that moment
where it was like, you kinda
never were that close again?
You just won your first race?
- My first Busch series race,
so the first race I ran.
- Ever!
- In the Xfinity Series.
- Okay.
Help me there, that's a
little confusing to me.
- It was 2003.
- That's not the triple a.
Got it.
- What I dunno how it goes,
does it go triple A, triple, double?
Okay, so triple A, Xfinity Series,
which was then.
- Which is the one right
before?
- Yeah.
It was 2003, it was my
first race ever in that car.
I qualified third, led a lot of laps,
and one of the big dogs
from the cup series
Matt Kensith beat me.
- Yeah I know that dude.
- I finished second, my first ever start.
Like that was crushing,
so then after that.
- But, in that crush, there must've been
while you were eating
some cheeseburger pissed
there must've been an underlying like
I'm gonna fucking kill all these guys.
'Cause if they're fuckin'
letting me come in second,
in my first fuckin' race,
you're in deep shit.
It's the way I think about Vayner media.
In the first year that
I kinda ran this company
I took it from three to 14 million.
And I was like, and I
just remember thinking
and we have devastating losses
where we came in second.
I just remember thinking,
you're in deep shit.
Vayner sports, my brother
and I now do football
representation, this was kind of like
our first official year.
And I'm in the living room
in the final two or three
for Sam Darnell and Josh Rosen,
the top quarterbacks
coming out of the race.
Into the league.
We didn't get either, but
when we didn't get them
all I thought about was,
these guys are in deep shit.
In the sports representation business,
'cause if you're letting
me in the fuckin' room
for the fuckin' number one
quarterbacks in year two
and we're still fuckin' dicking around
and haven't even really started,
I'm gonna slice your fuckin' throats.
Is that what you thought?
When you came in second.
- Yes.
- In that race, were you?
- Absolutely.
- Exactly.
- No question.
Hell yeah.
- Of course.
That's how we're ending
this fuckin' episode.
Punching seven year olds, slicing throats,
fuck it, I'm into this.
I'm gettin' fired up,
Kyle, thank you so much.
- All right man.
- For being here.
- Yeah, pleasure.
- As the guest
you get to ask the question of the day.
So all the people watching right now
this is a way for you to get
maybe some debate settled
or maybe you're curious about
what people are thinking
out there, you get to ask
the question of the day.
It can go in any.
By the way, you could ask
people favorite color,
I don't care where you go,
or you can be very thematic
to what we've been.
Question of the day.
- Hmm, all right, what made
you become a NASCAR fan
of today?
- Love it.
I can't wait to see all the
answers of this episode.
(laughing)
You keep asking questions!
We'll keep answering them.
(upbeat music)